what did writing your first screenplay
teach you about screenwriting oh my god
so when I wrote my first screenplay
I did now this is the difference between
writing a screenplay
and when I was directing before work my
first screenplay
of course see if is is like you know you
I don't think as a screenwriter I don't
think that you can really be a stylish
screenwriter if you have a study state
feels you know and vibrate a lot of
screenplays
tons of screen planes before I even
started writing screenplays I read see
it feels but cannot continue to read his
books you know but tons of screenplays
so when I first bought my first
screenplay you know and that's not that
you know it never got produced of course
and I took it out people really you
think that's pretty decent but it wasn't
good it wasn't good so it was only I
wrote it was only after after writing at
least 10 screenplays before I actually
decided you know before I actually
produce my own stuff so but it taught me
a lot they told me a lot like that I
didn't play with it all because I knew
that in order to sit down and write
there has to be a particular structure
and that's what when one of these two is
that one of the things is very important
as screenwriters in this film make is
that when you when you're pitching to
people to the producers you have to make
sure that the screenplay is properly
structured if you use a final draft and
you have to invest in like you have to
really we have to really really invest
in ourselves in our craft go out and get
the final Jeff program go out and reset
feels book and know how to read tons of
tons of screenplays you know and make
sure that when you actually pitch to
producers that's properly format it
there's nothing worse than someone said
they haven't I desperately hoping idea
and they pitch you an idea but they want
you to write the idea like I have tons
of screenplays or filmmakers or
screenwriters want you to read their
screenplays and it's not properly
formatted I hate that I'm like there's
no way I can't like recently someone
gave me asked me to read their
screenplay
they had they heading and everything was
written like a like a play I was like
there's a difference between a
screenplay in a stage play and in I
don't think people understand that when
you're writing a screenplay it's
formatted and it is formatted a
particular way because we're dealing
with different setups those are very
important and I had to explain to the
person who it was just read it I was
like it's hard to for me as a filmmaker
that's hard to follow when you don't
have like the proper headings on it you
know like the interior I don't know
where I'm at in the story just don't I
can't follow it and put those are very
important weather because like now we
have this this is one set up so if we go
outside then that's a different set up
so you have to make sure that you that
is that is in the screen playing like
it's an exterior so I've read
screenplays we can even have that I'm
like there's no way I can read this
because if people don't understand they
think you hating because you is you
they're making it difficult to read
their screenplays because they don't
want to follow the proper structure you
Polly you follow the proper structure
then it would make it much easier for us
to read the screenplay
yeah how was it for you to get your
first feedback because you know you
talked about feedback earlier in the
interview and how it's important and was
it the first time you showed someone
your screenplay
what was that feel oh god it was it was
the feedback I got was okay you know it
was it's something that you have to grow
into in evolve but again like me a smart
a this is this this is not properly this
is not you know you you like or the
story is not connecting you like why why
you get it you can get off edit bad but
the thing is is that you can't be
because if we want to grow evolve we
have to listen to constructive criticism
and you know if someone is like telling
you giving you some constructive
criticism I know it's hard for us to
deal with it it was hard for me today is
like still today you know when the
people get I have to be more open-minded
no when we when we need my screenplays
and people give me you know I you know
it's it's difficult you have to train
your mind like I have to always train my
mind that that or keep telling myself
that I think this is necessary
this is necessary this feedback is
necessary because sometimes we don't
want to you know I was just watching the
movie the wife oh yes excellent yes
excellent movie excellent
and when his wife gave him that feedback
he just blew up right because he didn't
want to hear that you know he didn't
want to hear that feedback you know so
but but at the end of the day well if he
had a listen to it he probably would
have become a better writer and instead
of her you know I'm gonna tell a story
it's better you know her what happened
but you know we have to listen to those
voices that give us those voices that
give us that constructive criticism so
we can evolve I know it's difficult so
even today I always happen when I'm
letting someone read my screenplay and
they giving me feedback on them I have
to keep telling myself over and over
again this is necessary
I need this you know is in when it when
it when that feedback is difficult to
hear
just repeat I need this I need this
because it's very important it's it's to
to allow us to grow in for us to evolve
and just put the ego aside you know we
have to put that ego aside at all times
even while I'm sick put the ego outside
and listen to the people who can make
our projects better
you